owning this is interesting your champion
women as part of your foundation because
obviously you've had an illustrious
career you're at the top of your game
but it's still very difficult for the
majority of women to follow that kind of
path it seems absolutely and
particularly worldwide when you look at
the opportunity swimming they are less
than the opportunities for men and it's
for a number of reasons firstly across
the world women don't get the same
educational opportunities as men so
that's the first start they don't get
the knowledge on top of that women tend
to not have the access to the capital to
the network's to the support networks
that they need and women often have lack
confidence why do they like confidence
because society is telling them this is
not what women do and therefore to
actually set stand up and say no this is
what I do and this is why I want to
succeed goes against that culture it is
interesting we're building up to
International Women's Day and when you
look out there at the moment the role
models are there we've got a female
prime minister we've got women heading
up the police force the army the UK
Supreme Court we've got a female doctor
who then in the papers today we've got
the first-ever female pilot at British
Airways coming out and saying that
across the airline industry women aren't
supported when it comes to maternity
allowance and support to help them get
back to work so it's obvious that you
know you have these female role models
but the steps aren't in place yet for
other women to get there
well role models are important because
first of all if you never actually see a
successful woman politician then you're
less likely as a young girl to think
that can be me once you do see that
women can make it to the top it really
does make a difference but of course if
it's always seen as these women are the
exceptions it's always seen that these
are the women who have had to sacrifice
other parts of their lives in order to
get there then you're not really
creating a level playing field so
whether it's issues about maternity pay
or maternity leave or whether it's a
more general question of whether women
are getting a fair chance in the world
it's really important that we see a
commitment a commitment by everybody to
make this happen
and that's why this partnership that my
foundation is having with Avon and their
stand for her campaign is so important
because Avon is a as a brand which is
about cosmetics obviously which is
something about women use cosmetics to
help their confidence it's a very
important part of that but it's also a
brand that reaches over a hundred
million women a year so by reaching out
to them and helping them in their
entrepreneurship journey by giving them
access to training and support we can
really shift the needle what was your
journey like because it's interesting
there you talk about the attitude of all
women can't do that and when you started
out in your legal career back in the 70s
I would imagine that was much more
prevalent than it is now what was your
journey like and particularly the legal
profession do you still see that
attitude around well sadly I think it's
true that though we find many more women
going into the legal profession when I
was it went into the legal profession it
was the first year to God above 10% now
it's you know roughly 50/50 going in but
when you look at how women progress
through the profession it's still the
case that women are dropping out and
we're still seeing issues for example
like sexual harassment and and bullying
within the workplace then women tend to
suffer from that it's interesting isn't
it you obviously had battles to fight in
your legal career but you were also
thrust into public life as the wife of
the Prime Minister Tony Blair and just
looking back at some of the coverage of
you during your time at number 10 with
your husband
there was this undertone in fact quite
often it was an undertone of a sexist
attitude towards you in terms of you
were a career woman whose husband just
happened to be Prime Minister so you
know there was newspaper coverage that
was almost like the cheek of it that she
has a career while her husband who's
Prime Minister or how dare she have
views on things you know when her
husband is Prime Minister how did she
deal with that because that can be the
attitude sometimes when it comes comes
to women in public life well sure I mean
you know that's why I called my book
speaking for myself because you know you
say of course I'm entitled to have views
but when your husband's the Prime
Minister it's you have to be careful how
you express those views because you're
not a
sensitive of the government and if you
want to be representative of the
government you should stand for election
yourself
I mean complaining about the press is
like complaining about the British
whether it was just that it was just
that underlying attitude of she's a
career woman you know and it's almost
like they'd begrudged you that because
you had a family you had a husband in a
very important role I always took the
view that just because my husband had
changed his job when gone into number
ten that didn't mean I should give up my
career because I had spent a long time
building up my career and become a QC
before my husband became a prime
minister yeah and there was a kind of
assumption when I first went in from the
system itself from Downing Street itself
that surely I would give up my job so
they were slightly surprised when I said
well no I want to continue with my job
because it's something that belongs to
me
and since your new husband left number
ten I mean obviously we talked about the
role of women we've touched on the role
of women in the legal system but also in
politics as well and there's been this
whole me too movement and some very
uncomfortable findings within
westminster there are people say haven't
been properly addressed what have you
made of a culture that it's sort of been
peeled back and seen what's going on
underneath and the public oh actually
quite disappointed with attitudes in
westminster in the treatment of women i
don't know well i'm sure the public are
disappointed but i'm not sure they're
entirely surprised because I think those
attitudes towards women whether it's
just about bossy females rather than you
know confident men the this is an
underlying trend in society what we're
talking about is allowing women the
opportunity as 50% of the population to
have equal access to all levels of
society and equal chances with men and
the truth is across the world there is
no country where that actually happens
and in some countries in the world for
example there are still countries in the
world where women can't even work or
leave the country without the permission
of their male relatives and you know
that is not treating women as equal
actors with equal dignity to men so we
have to do something about this idea
that somehow women are the inferior sex
it's interesting isn't it because we
look at government
and the political system as setting the
tone for these changes and there's a lot
of talk at the moment about the
political system being broken I mean
we've seen this breakaway group of MPs
a lot of people saying you know
government isn't fit for purpose when it
comes to tackling gender equality sexism
if this is you know held up as the
example of the country particularly with
gender inequality the treatment of
female politicians like Hannah Seabury
Diane Abbott
Luciana burger so you do wonder if
change can be effective effective if
that is the model that people are
looking at at the moment people think
it's broken well but if you look at the
figures again about where are women
getting equality across the world the
World Economic Forum do this report
about the global gender gap and they
look at four areas and you see in health
and education the gap is narrowing but
if you look at the areas where if you
like the power is which is economic
activity and political activity then the
gap is much bigger in economic
opportunity that gap between men and
women is like 64 women per 100 men and
for politics it's in the low 20s so it's
still showing that when you look at
where power is situated in the world
women are not getting equal access to
that and if we look at youth today and
the importance of ensuring that our
youth have the opportunities Klan
International just on a report where
they estimate that there are six hundred
and twenty eight million young people
between 16 and 25 across the world who
are not in education and don't have
access to employment and if you look and
break down that figure a little more you
discover that the vast majority of those
young girls young women who are not
getting that first step on the education
rather and then I'm not being enabled to
express themselves to find themselves to
go on a journey to be able to support
themselves and that's why
entrepreneurship is one of the keys to
this because if we can help more women
entrepreneurs come into the economy so
that they can devise their businesses
suit themselves that can suit the way
they work so that they can combine their
work with their family obligations then
we will not only increase the world a
gross domestic product which is a good
thing in itself but even more important
will enable women to take their rightful
place in society so that they are
respected that their voices are heard
and they can stand up to things like
bullying sexual violence or just the
complete neglect of women's issues